hello welcome back to GameSpot's
continuing coverage of e3 2015 live from
the other Convention Center right here
in beautiful Los Andes California I'm
Daniel Dwyer joined by Roland my friend
from Avalanche great job on the Giant
Bomb stage last night you you held your
own in a in a murderer's row crazy
people it was it was definitely a lot of
crazy people there was a lot of fun
you guys are real busy over at Avalanche
before we went live we're talking about
the Mad Max stuff which is coming out
real soon actually real soon yeah but
you're on the real crazy Project Just
Cause 3 Rico Rodriguez is back he is
back and it is a beautiful explosive
weird creative sandbox and we've only
got you here for 15 minutes or so I
believe there's some sort of crazy
trailer interactive trailer madness
we're gonna kick off yeah so let's get
into it now so we can have it playing
while were chatting I like it so the
idea here is we're just going to jump
straight into Medici this is a four
hundred square mile world it is
absolutely enormous and like all the
Just Cause games you can go anywhere so
the beach over there the mountains in
the distance that base all the way far
in the distance you see right there
we're actually going to go check that
out a little bit later as we go diving
through all this but of course the
parachute is back it is infinite as it
always has been
you guys have stays stay true to the
grapple and parachute combination it is
goes to it's definitely there and where
there's a little bit of a story now why
you have infinite grapple infinite
parachutes it sucks back in this time so
those are the frames of animation there
okay have you figured you guys are all
sitting infinite c4 though yeah there's
a lot of c4 well I mean the idea of like
having an explosion always at your
fingertips you don't want to go looking
for it so we decided we'll just give you
a whole bunch of it and you can plant it
anywhere it's like a planted explosive
but because of it you actually have to
land somewhere and plant it so there's a
little bit of okay I wouldn't call it
strategy you know that's it's not really
that sort of subtle but it's not like
you're just flailing grenades everywhere
right exactly and it means that you
don't have to put explosive barrels in
literally every corner of the game there
there might be explosive barrels it
literally every corner of the game let's
let's talk about the setting because
obviously the the carribean is that the
setting of the ball we think about with
Just Cause and this is the Mediterranean
though right we are in the Mediterranean
now so
so the mediterranean-inspired well-liked
Pinal which was kind of a fictionalized
Island I did the same thing with Betty
so it's not quite a betta it's not quite
a betta but there's a lot of inspiration
south of France Greece Italy I mean it's
it's been a ton of fun building the
world so here we go we're gonna look at
a little bit of destruction here all
right you can make a choice so we're
looking at the statue which was one of
the iconic pieces of propaganda yes but
we've done a relationship now at havoc
which means that we've done all sorts of
havoc destructions so right actually
will destroy different ways every time
and you can choose any way you feel like
destroying the statue okay
and stop hitting yourself all right I
like that one it's been a bit favor for
the team to be honest I think a lot of
people online a bit like at this one so
yeah let's do it so good thank god
number two here the farmers revenge look
good as an Irishman I can appreciate
that it's good it's a tractor with
nitrous on it okay so Rico grapples up
here we wanted to make it really
seamless moving around the world and
we'll look a little bit more of that in
a second and here you'll see the
multiple tethers so instead of having
one tether you can now do multiple
tethers in the world we're planning
somewhere between five and six right now
we have six but everything's about
tuning in the end and it's ridiculous
huge chains of destruction because of it
and now you can actually control the
tether and of course your coins and
awesome ways I mean one thing that we
won't is Froy though we won't destroy
the head okay grapple it around and use
it as a wrecking ball great why not
how many grapples can you do so right
now we're we're planning kind of up to
600 but we're still tuning it to figure
out what feels best yes sometimes it
starts getting just madness yep
presumably that's like in terms of I
don't pretend to be a programmer but
there's a lot of physics [ __ ] happening
there with six grapples it's a lot of
physics I mean there are times where
simulating over four million objects the
same time oh my god why it's a next-gen
only game so you're able to stick
rumple's to two different things that
basically retract them yeah you can
control the retract strength yourself
and that's on the left trigger all the
time and it just means that you fully
control everything and of course we like
explosions and so that was the new gas
station explosion part of it was like
well we need to go bigger right and then
we just kept going bigger we would break
the build a little the populists
love massive explosions Enrico doesn't
think that's my favorite thing just goes
I wanted to was shooting someone's car
and then like grappling onto it and just
being like it's like a bucking bronco
solid situation so this is a new
wingsuit
excellent so after stabilizing the
parachute making it a real combat
platform you know really fun and easy to
shoot from we needed another great
traversal so wings who feels amazing
it's really good combine that with the
grapple that you get to do the sorts of
soaring through the world that is
absolutely insane and it's my turf
amazing yeah and what I really actually
did I've noticed it here is the I love
how almost a big Rico raised and also
the depth of field you're working with
with him like sitting so far in torso
going in the foreground yeah we play a
lot with where cameras are how it moves
we wanted to give this like that giant
open feel the enormous vistas that
you're used to yeah but with all that
fidelity of next-gen like we have
destruction even on our vegetation will
see a little bit later now this kind of
idea of being in this just epically
beautiful place and then blowing the
hell out of it and one of the most
interesting things that came out of Just
Cause 2 especially on the PC was that
the modding community really grabbed it
and that that sort of was it a hundred
person and multiplayer actually know
what let's do that lets just relax
choice first so here we're at like a
port base so this is kind of water base
we've done a whole new physicalize water
system inside so all these boats will
come in but right now we have these
giant spherical fuel tanks okay that we
can blow up in pretty much any way you
want it says a lot that I like I like
the look of the bowling ball because of
the physics but I kind of want to see a
jet so let's let's do the jet the Jets
Larry okay all right what's the bowling
ball just like rolls remove all we use
our dual tethering cuz every single
chaos object now actually is physicalize
itself
yeah there's no health meter on it so
you can rip it in the constraints rip
off so you can actually use it like a
bowling ball and smash other things or
you can use a jet or you can get on a
jet and stunt straight out of it in a
parachute
and use it like a giant bullet just blow
the hell out of the world that spherical
fuel tank explosion I sat there with the
guys being like can you do something
bigger have a bigger net bigger than
that come on
bigger they've also got sick of me I
think the effects guys are like stop
stop all right here it is it's as big as
you would leave possible I like it and
we talked a little bit the or I started
talking about the mods and two questions
about that actually one and multiplayer
what are you guys doing with that is
gonna be the same scale as what they did
in the modding community gnarly we
really wanted to concentrate on the
single-player experience and the thing
that really hit on Just Cause 2 and I
know the multiplayer thing people really
love the idea of being out there but we
wanted to get the experience of sharing
your videos people do crazy things
themselves so they want to set up nine
different things all together and be
able to do awesome stuff and then share
that stuff online and we did a thing on
JC too with the ps3 oh yeah that
vehicles are all new destruction for the
fields to get sunflowers I like it at
the at ridiculous and we wanted to get
the the modding feel more than anything
else which is a game that's your sandbox
do it you want so we have tons of online
features that are always tracking what
you're doing is the longest time
wingsuiting how fast you can kill five
people with an explosion OH all that
stuff and you can challenge your friends
on it and that kind of interactivity is
there but who's to say what's going to
happen in the future
awesome and let's say let's pick the
next one I'm gonna hear we're gonna talk
about a bridge so we didn't just do
destruction with chaos objects we did it
in the world itself so even our enormous
bridges you can take down but they like
come back so you can do it over and over
again I'm gonna let you pick this one
because you know which one is which
one's the self and the hydro missiles
awesome cuz you're in a in parachute
shooting a shotgun style RPG okay I kind
of like chop chop I don't really really
seen that as much it's our new
helicopter and it like just wreaks havoc
it has both mini guns and missiles on it
extra the boss all right let's check it
at every shop chop I think that's the
right the waves looks good as well but I
that's a pretty good way of breaking
into a helicopter just shoot the door
over yeah we took away the interactions
right there and it's there's still a
little bit of gameplay because you have
to be careful getting into a militarized
video this is a little bit of a pause
and you can still get shot on it but
it's quick and it's violent cos Rico
uses explosions to open a door oh man
bad news just like just like what
happens when I've ever play like bridge
construction simulator am are you guys
going up or do it on the motorway he did
he die man kept driving
he should have seen that Carmen was like
a helicopter who's like if Rico is here
I should go anywhere that could be
destroyed gtfo are you going to go do it
I think with like people being able to
like share clips obviously on the
next-gen consoles that's a baby next gen
consoles already there they have a
button that literally does it for you
and they're recording already so it was
all inbuilt in fact when we first sat
down with Sony and Microsoft saying okay
we want to do this new game they're like
oh here's our new console yeah like oh
it's all you've done right erage thank
you so I think it's gonna be awesome I
mean already some of the youtubers out
there and twitch streams that we've done
the fans have been amazing about it and
we're getting in the hands of youtubers
now they start playing with the build
and vessel around and then do something
so you're no longer fixed anywhere you
can just walk around right I want
backflip off of that use it as an
explosion it's it's awesome and we're
going to go now from a plane over to a
motorcycle bike awesome we're gonna head
up to that base we looked at earlier
that was off in the distance this base
is really more about a highly vertical
you can do combat from motorcycles
enemies can ride motorcycles and fight
you on it they can lean out of windows
and shoot you all of our vehicles are
now hinged parts and deformations we
have this awesome new vehicle system we
redid the vehicles from scratch so
they're weighty
you can drift them you can after touch
them in the air we've done mods against
it so any vehicle that you collect in
the world you can then like add nitrous
or our like Knight Rider inspired turbo
jump great basically means any vehicle
you can just jump to imagine like a
tractor you can just nitrous around that
right so that's our next like my dad
used to
oh we got here you want to go we're
gonna enter this base in a madman style
I like it I like a tank let's go with a
overkill is underrated and just a last
question on the modding front just cuz
I'm a massive modern myself as well or
about user of mods rather and obviously
the PC crowd are probably going to go
and do crazy stuff make their big
multiplayer stuff and we saw with the
fallout guys that they're actually
Microsoft's allowing them to bring that
stuff over onto the consoles if there
was ever that stuff being made on PC do
you guys have any pipeline for getting
that onto the Xbox one we've been
wanting to do quite a lot of that stuff
for a while we're not announcing
anything there yet but a lot of the devs
that work on the game and a lot of us in
general who work in games came out of
the Monica cavity we came out of messing
with games and you know we would want to
support that as much as possible and
it's such a it's such a nice thing in JC
to so many mods on it that's that's the
greatest thing in the world is to have
someone mod your game yeah I love it
that's their personal talk yeah they
want to spend their personal time so
we're gonna do everything we can to make
sure it's easy to mess around with the
game as much as possible another cool
thing I remember when the guys GameSpot
went to play there's a judge this week
and that you guys turned on the dev
tools to allow them to sort of do
whatever they want I was actually
playing the first crackdown last week
and I remembered that they had this guy
keys to the city mode which basically
allowed you it turned off achievements
and all that stuff but alleged you like
spawn and weapon spawn and stuff put on
god mode like do you guys ever think you
could you just let that stuff happen in
the game just kind of like a you know
what maybe somebody's want to blow up
some crap you know maybe it looks like
you guys are kind of a kind of already
servicing that but the fix a lot of
everybody give any like plans they allow
some sort of like a dev tool mode in the
game we talked about it a lot and
actually a lot of our design is inspired
in that way anyways so we've actually
been sitting there and even our rebel
drop systems our ability to get you know
a vehicle any weapon that you want you
actually drop them all at the same time
and there's no cutscene it just like
shows up in a box on the ground you're
like I want a jet right now and an RPG
and you're like boom right so you kind
of already build it
the gameplay and we gotta add a little
bit of the story around like how that
works but yeah we wanted to put it in
there but you know we we've been talking
a lot about supporting this game for a
long time to come Square Enix is an
amazing partner in that they want this
game to live on they see four or five
hundred thousand people still playing JC
- Wow they're saying you know this game
is five years ago five years so that I
we're gonna support this game for a long
time which is great news for DES because
we love making this game
awesome rollin thank you so much for
your time today very much looking
forward to to playing with playing with
Rico Rodriguez and sure why not thanks
very much and best of luck finishing at
the game yeah we're gonna be here on the
e3 show for all day long all day long if
you're watching this in the USA hey
doing good morning good afternoon if
you're watching this in Europe
don't go is sleep we've got so much
stuff happening today I got loose start
on four Skylanders supercharge I
literally got talked to Lou start three
years in a row on the e3 stage and we
got rigs on we got FIFA and Madden and
then later on today I'll be back on I
would show him where he from no man sky
as stick around
and next up Lou start with Skylanders
supercharge stay there
you
[Music]